okay when is my birthday July 2nd I
already know your birthday don't want to
do that you have the tail I didn't even
want that question that code should be
in there I'm trying to plan on what I'm
gonna get you for your birthday
hey what's up sweetie I'm here with
quavo to hunt show today we don't see
how well he knows me with these
questions
it's the GQ couples Queen and the first
question is what's my favorite color
okay yep one point actually you get
point eight cuz you should've known
I'm trying to make it dramatic because
we've got cameras they want to answer
that bad all right what are my parents
names Mamah Cheney and eye color oh gee
pops I call the pop noise first name
it's like an econ emoji so I'm gonna
give you you know that was a two point
question you get one point okay what I'm
most scared of scary movies hell yeah he
always want to have you watch scary
movies I will not watch no scary movies
look at you baby you get two points
better all right where did I go to spoon
it was San Diego State and USC Cairo me
know to point questions two points
transferred so you want to avoid Mary
keep meeting you at the questions was my
major oh my god business communication
system let it yeah you know the he's
trying to be dramatic girl
what food do I hate hate
and what food do I love food you love
those oysters hey a lot of difference
well I like everything he eats Oh what
kind of food you hate that's a real good
question
I don't know that I really didn't know I
eat the same food over and over again so
I'll try to figure out what food do I
not like do you like artists that hates
it yeah what are you right baby food she
got this figure rated without her juices
is green I'm like what a sprite and food
punches and I won't like gushes in
cabinets she got I seaweed chips who was
my celebrity crush me there's been like
that before she met me she was like oh
he was fine you know I like his hair his
face is live where did we go on our
first date
Mady City interesting it was a holiday
like the day we entered it with majesty
the first crime yeah we went to the we
went to a restaurant cost on the river
she came to Atlanta so I just kind of
like just shoulder to shoulder like went
to the studio being an artist she was
amazed that we built that building you
know I'm saying coming from what we came
from and I just showed it an outsider we
ended it off with Madison what is our
favorite show to wash together it was
late been on Godfather
she made me watch the throne what's the
throne thing Game of Thrones oh my god I
ended up liking because we end up doing
like some things for now cuz I heard
that he's writing alternative ending and
I don't like hugging Ares went out
that's my girl
what was I wearing when we first met
let's go that way
you switch enough so much man how was my
hair blonde yeah let the blind and you
pull it up in a yg wedding
it was funny cuz I had just got my yg
wagon when he was like pull up on me
house I hear you how about the bullet do
you know okay
you know thing loud coming down the
streets not a mover what is my favorite
song of yours well I tried come on when
he was on tour like I go crazy and every
time I do his ad-libs he look at me and
pointing at me and I just be going off
so that's not even if I don't point her
she'd get mad at me and I'll be coming
off the stage was wrong he wanted me on
I was a fan of his what's your biggest
pet peeve about me you're the greatest
every night to take long his hair to
come to bed that's the biggest pet
peeves you ever to get in the bed every
time she come out the bathroom or asleep
no so I'm a wild sleeper oh my god that
- no that's no that's like the bed is
this way she was like across the bed is
like war at night sometimes trying to
get to scoop all the way over on her
side of the bed cuz she like oh well my
side leaving me like a little strip
that's too peppy yeah I'm gonna take a
long time to come to visit I ever seen
you know you guys I can makeup off you
have to moisturize the top toner slide
yeah I'm sleep by that time what am I
most comfortable sleeping in
right mm-hmm that's how I got here every
night like before I will go to sleep
when we first met hello what's my
nickname for you chocho big Gary Harper
what do I like most about you very
handsome and you like my smile bye Monty
love my skin like some oh stuff and just
hold it down
he named everything that was a loaded
question baby you get some bonus points
today
what's my middle name yeah
ain't that like you it's like what if I
would have went my Keala it would have
been key I'm an quavo there's like two
Q's what's my astrological sign what is
that only no that is oh I don't know
what that is I don't even know stuff
like that I don't know what that is what
you anyway
what's my favorite fast-food and what do
I like to order there you just had this
the other night Lucy OH
in and out
yeah yeah what's my guilty pleasure
[Laughter]
yeah gonna have to you know listen for
that culture 3 so you know find out what
my guilty pleasure how long does it take
to do lawmaker depends if we going
somewhere cool about a hour and 20 food
somewhere that means some about two
hours of 20 mm-hmm so fellows will show
ladies like you can't just be telling us
that we going somewhere like a five
minutes just consider this y'all ready
come with beautiful features up there
they're gonna beat this thing
slap it on real fast and just run out
the door now I got a contour got a
powder I got a baked and saucer process
baby how often do I get my nails done
how long you had no more than you see
you know my favorite thing you switch it
up in like a week and a half
that's why what are three things I never
leave the house without your phone of
course that's easier well I see lip
gloss
and yeah eyelashes
yep can you wrap the first few bars of I
see girl and you start lost our gig but
my toes and until I have everything and
I say I mean my arsenal
oh no but let's follow yeah we don't got
a sign
that's a good question we'll come back
to y'all yeah we will give us something
where am i fast I'm gonna babe what are
some of the dances we do from the bags
[Laughter]
[Music]
spicy sauce co-sleeping turn a Swedish
spice what irritates me the most
can I be on heart might be on the body
or hard I can be interpreted what I know
it in me I know the media detail at it
okay what's my favorite store to shop a
I just need a bag and let you go no he
goes I like my street fight all day on
places like there was no stuff like that
you cream just let me know I will make
sure that no what's my favorite sonnet
or to most other seasons like regular
girlfriends it's working
my girlfriend be in the club what was my
first song I ever made cause it was a
car wreck no no you made some other you
don't want me to go back to the other
other song you may have a say again say
yeah she got some song I don't know what
name it is does ecology if you look up
the og sweetie she got some song the
folk anyway I hate social media because
it really allows somebody do they
research on you when you first met me he
whispered me like hello eclipse' me
rapping me guys got somewhere hmm what
word do I overuse notice right like it
could be used in like so many different
ways or he could be like excited like
I'm not know what's mine what is
something that you wasn't expecting
about me that she went without me
oh that she was whoops in yes yeah
when I came to her house is always on
ESPN ha like she was kind of happy that
would like turn on watch TV be on
SportsCenter and he'd be like it was
over here but that's what made me like
okay cool that's all
alright so final question baby how well
you think you did on this quiz mmm I
think I did good I did good I think I
want did I win he wants you to score let
me see baby yes yes let's go yup alright
so for my last question what do you want
to do after this
[Music]